this week conflict zone is back in the
West Bank city of Ramallah home of the
Palestinian Authority and the Palestine
Liberation Organization my guest is
Hanan Ashrawi a member of the PLO
Executive Committee who has campaigned
tirelessly for decade against Israeli
occupation so how are the Palestinians
facing up to the new Trump era and is
the so-called two-state solution already
dead and buried
[Music]
have a nice rally welcome to come Victor
thank you to the new Trump
administration if they should move the
US Embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
they've had to a recognition of Israel's
capital as being in Jerusalem yes I your
president cover that back says he'll use
diplomatic and legal channels to fight
it that's meaningless isn't it you can't
fight it
of course you can fight it and we should
write it because it is illegal and it is
in many ways becoming complicit with the
occupation it is violating their own
statute but if the US and Israel decide
that's it well then they will unleash
now they will unleash a whole new
dynamic in the region and beyond and the
dynamic violence you're talking about
violence I'm talking about anger
hostilities environments possibly
violence extremism because this is an
extreme position and at your logical
position it will feed its counterpart
but profit is your environment you know
what can't self-fulfilling so do you
make a prophecy like that is going to
happen yeah that's the usual fallacy
always blame the person who want you
against introducing a bull into a china
shop you don't blame the person who
brought in the bullets I have a barrel
of oil there has the law and inner
violence and we've been trying
desperately to stop the violence
unfortunately when you have ideological
positions when as values as power
politics and violence and gets away with
it and when it uses absolutist ideology
and gets away with it
a gently feeds its counterpart on the
other side John Kerry had to warn you
recently former Secretary of State the
last administration against continuing
incitement to Vienna from the
Palestinian side I know he's not buying
this line but you're not talking about
you are ever being in cycling yes we
have been yeah I think he's been
desperately trying to find a way to show
some sorts of symmetry that we are going
to blame both sides the aggressor and
the victim the occupier and the occupied
so very not a convenient explanation
isn't it but it now second most ability
for what you
do the convenient way of approaching the
issue by trying to allocate blame
equally knowing that this is not a
symmetrical situation you cannot blame
people under occupation all the time for
whether incitement of violence when you
know that it is systematic violence
being exercised against you can't be oh
you're a firefighter can you run on a
show get going give them a free class
either the quartet in July spoke about
your incitement is that some members of
factor have publicly supported attacks
and their perpetrators as well as
encouraged violent confrontation genious
artificial recycles arbitrators as
heroes and a crown on the head of every
Palestinian there I've seen well of
course that I heard individuals and some
but they are seen by the people as
resistance and you cannot somehow adopt
the language of either the international
community or the occupier by describing
anybody who resists as a terrorist this
whole labeling thing this whole
stereotypical situation is not only
unfair and unjust but it also distorts
reality and it prevents you from dealing
with it justly we're knocking about
semantics with knowing what you
encouraging violence these are
statements that encourage people to go
under you want to hold retinue driver
responsible for this statement of
everything and Palestinian then you
should do the same for their service
there are individual Israelis about what
they do we're talking to you about what
the Palestinian but it's both I mean it
works both ways you are blaming the
victim for the animal and it lets the
Palestinians answer for what they do the
Israelis will have to answer for what
they do it doesn't help that have you
heard official statements from the
president from the government from PLO
executive members encouraging violence I
think you have heard always statements
against violence I'm calling for
nonviolent resistance Chanukah we posed
to take the higher moral ground is it
taking the moral high ground when your
senior chief negotiator Saeb Erekat
in 2015 goes and visits and offers
comfort to a Palestinian family of a man
who murdered an Israel and was killed
himself
kind of signal do you think that said
yeah you call that mother decide maybe
it's not like that killing the
individual TL EDA it was a little his
relatives who who did that and he was
going to do the family obligation but at
the same time what is the Israeli army
doing on Palestinian land what are the
settlers doing on Palestinian land you
want to end the violence and with all
over the place and end the source of
violence which is the occupation by
Israel and the ongoing oppression and
they called bloody systematic violence
against captive actually nobody believes
I don't even get your leaders the
Palestinians to condemn random violence
against Israelis I got the answer
repeatedly that we are against violence
yes but you went down amount and condemn
it when I asked the Prime Minister here
last year to condemn the violence and
the stabbings he refused to do it
what kind of signal does that send
because that sends a signal that you
have adopted the language of asymmetry
that you are willing to adopt the
language of Israel blaming the victim
while you are not talking about Israeli
violent up to very nicely off your
situation that's why I think you are
pretty shocked look at all these
statements of a so statements they all
condemn violence and that's important
because I think the Palestinians have
been using extreme restraint so when any
individual somehow loses it as a result
of demolishing his house or her house
killing his or her mother or sister or
brother expelling them from their city
or whatever when they the act and when
they lash out then it's very easy to
label all the Palestinians and blame
them is the truth of look it isn't the
truth of this but your to add to week
even to stop violence you can't even
stop violence between your own faction
carriers can you stop violence or
animality in any place okay Pandy it's
at a different level
no at a different level what did we had
last October we had a staunch critic of
mr. Abbas body else al-amin
he had 60 bullets fired at his house
because of his criticism by unknown
gunmen quite a price to pay for pretty
much any employers and you blame what
the presidental blend the faction why
are you not control anyone why are you
can't control violence among your own
factions
how do you do that can you control
violence and criminality in Germany and
Britain use that try it on a completely
different level is my tell you something
they try to the point where they are
being criticized by their own people I
don't want to see a police state here I
don't want you to expect and oppress
people under occupation to behave not
only like angels but to lie down and die
quietly or turn the other cheek and then
blame them if they don't you use Uniform
Standards do you blame the government if
there is an individual who carries out
an act of violence in any country no you
look at not any country and the levels
of violence ahead of any other country
are subject to tremendous provocation we
are subject to as you means that to
absolve you of all responsibility for
improving and reforming and doing what's
necessary in your own precise message
you reuse the Israeli excuse don't at
all we don't relish the idea of
victimhood and we will not use our
victimhood as an excuse to do unto
others what was done unto us all right
this is the situation now we are trying
to maintain a system of rule of law a
system of respect for rights and
freedoms freedom of expression including
and at the same time we are under
occupation we are in a situation of
tremendous injustice and I will come on
- come on - your respect for freedom of
expression in a minute but I want to I
want I want to make you less because you
want us in many ways to absorb the
occupation of its role and to treat the
Palestinians as though they are
responsible for everything that happens
to them and I think these two are Salafi
and you want to blow the mobile
responsibility not at all let us talk a
moment about the recent Security Council
resolution basically critical of Israeli
settlements in the web and I
America refused to block the resolution
it's called the settlements a flagrant
violation of international law you
wanted
you know it for it it was a big deal for
you you got it and yet you've no follow
up offer you don't do anything to follow
up on this about this response was the
minute the Israeli government agrees to
cease all settlement activities and
agrees to implement the find agreements
on the basis of mutual reciprocity then
we're ready to resume talks but I don't
own it that's all going to happen what
do you want I mean you know it wasn't
going to happen but you got the best
diplomatic boost now in in a long time
and one normally Obama yeah from the
Obama outgoing Obama administration but
from you the same title is before is a
resolution that entitled response
William is complete all sorts of UN
resolutions condemning settlements
condemning settlement expansion
condemning Israel's illegal annexation
of Jerusalem
we have scores of these resolutions
Israel has not implemented or honored a
single one so now okay we have to see
before we want to build on it we want to
move ahead so we are urging Israel the
international community to honor it and
to another commitment Israel says that
well it did free settlement building you
didn't come to the table either you may
know it for 10 months you know better
I don't know better I prefer it when
they said there's no settlements what
did they do they excluded the major
settlement settlement blocs they
excluded East Jerusalem and its
environment
they also excluded all the contracts
that they have given out compared to
what they're doing now so the trend is
Trump came into power that's 1 2 3 it's
tender you didn't take advantage of now
that wasn't this please
that wasn't that's a wrong conclusion
I'm sorry compared to what do they're
doing now this is an added escalation
but if you look at the numbers Israel
had built much more during the so-called
freeze than it did before
because it gave itself a free hand to
build in these blocks to build in
Jerusalem and to continue contract and
if use this semantically you see Israeli
spin in many ways gets adopted by the
international community and sometimes by
the press in order to avoid dealing with
allottee deal with reality not with is
version I come back to the Potter and I
come back to the point that you keep
blaming all your problems on Israel as a
way of avoiding looking after them
exactly realization I don't think that
you I think actually let's look at the
problems let's look at the middle of our
own system and I've been very outspoken
in many cases yes let's look at the
problems within your political
establishment you have too much power
for instance in the president's hands
we're not getting reforms we have
nepotism and corruption in the
Palestinian Authority as abdel kader al
husseiny the chairman of the coalition
for accountability and integrity said
not on a bluff when she was half-asian
he said that he wanted the legislative
council reactivated because otherwise
the anti-corruption Drive was
meaningless
absolute power he said means absolute
corruption so that's what you've got in
the Palestinian Authority yeah that's a
statement of fact that you are absolute
corrupt I don't think we have absolute
power yet but I think there are
instances of corruption but the
important thing is that we do have in
place several instruments in order to
deal with corruption not only do we have
the coalition for accountability and
integrity we also have the
anti-corruption Commission which is
formulated by law and has the powers to
hold people accountable we also have
several services you have a president
who refuses to name a successor keeps
all the power to himself effectively
preventing any kind of orderly transfer
of power yeah and you have bitter
infighting you will have busy infighting
over the succession he ensures that by
keeping all this Panthers leader after
leader of the PLO President of the
Palestinian Authority at 81 a sick man
refuses to name a successor and you
think that's progress usually said no
because he should name a successor I
think we should have elections we should
their elections for the president and
vice versa you can have a lot of people
are trying you having them all what do
you mean you're trying to have elections
just I just announced to have them when
they're trying to hide election we did
have election we did have an
announcement of election
and what happened was that the Hamas
section and Gaza managed to undermine
them by having its own courts try to
exclude the other factions candidates so
yes we have obstacles and we have
serious problems the problem is the
thing is do we have the will to deal
with them is that an active public
opinion and civil society are we trying
very hard to face these things and to
change them even under occupation which
you say we blame everything on this we
don't blame everything on the occupation
but when you're not free enough to move
from one place to the other in your own
country when you don't feel safe in your
own home when you could be detained or
arrested when I ran for office for the
PLC in Jerusalem
I was detained I was stopped at the
checkpoint I couldn't get to my
constituents in Jerusalem I was beaten
up they took away my elections documents
and platform and so on and I went to for
hours I couldn't get there so I'm not
saying that we don't want to have
elections because Israel eats a pizza
like that but at the same time this is
reality you you made a great play that
you're cracking down on corruption okay
more than saying you're trying more than
a year ago this Palestinian Coalition
for accountability and integrity flag
his own concerns on the corruption front
and nothing was done it cited a failure
to adopt a national comprehensive and
participatory plan against matters
Asterion
concerns with the ministry everyone but
we need it to be implemented more
accurate so it's just a piece of paper
no no it's implemented in part and
that's why we said you cannot have
anti-corruption partially you can't use
it selectively you have administrator
ionizer you have a Ministry of Finance
that is cease to disseminate budgets and
data you have an ongoing rise and now we
shall have a mat in a state institution
that's not - I'm telling you we've had
several meetings with the Minister of
Finance whether with a man the coalition
or the Parliament the PLC the
parliamentary blocks had meetings I have
a copy we all have a copy of the
proposed but you say you're sounding
very anti corruption isn't being in
command we are don't change the subject
I'm not sure
you know but resenting the budget by the
Minister of Finance and he did presented
we are looking at it and in a few days
we're having another meeting also with
the committee in the PLC to review the
budget again so we have it the problem
is the PLC itself is not functioning the
way it should be because of the rift of
expertise that's a major red line
between Hamas Hamas and Fatah West Bank
and Gaza and it's a serious problem you
talked about freedom of speech how much
you value freedom of speech last year
Human Rights Watch that most Palestinian
governments practice intimidation and
physical abuse of anyone who dares to
criticize them last year the Palestinian
Authority arrested and charged activists
and musicians whose only crime was to
ridicule the security forces for
cooperating with Israel accusing the
government of corruption you blame
Israel for violating its commitment your
government violates its commitments on
human rights and other things like a
corruption its promises it violates them
continually the International Covenant
on Civil and Political Rights you don't
respect that you don't respect the
Convention Against Torture and the
Palestinian basic law on freedom of
small you don't respect them our laws
are against any kind of violation of
yunda mention that we get a violation
and marvel and against torture and some
we get a nonetheless they are yes there
are violations but they're not as
pervasive as you try to present them
well I'm not presenting what the human
rights organization including your own
human rights organizations across the
board we've had several instances we are
addressing them there are even cases
where the Independent Commission on
Human Rights has even taken the
government to court so we are trying
using the court system using the laws
using civil society to come to them and
torture according to the Palestinian
Center for Human Rights torture
continues to be systematically practiced
in prisons and detention facilities in
the West Bank and Gaza Strip give me
give me statistics you don't you don't
read their reports we're not and of
course I did that approach my policy
Center for Human Rights as though it is
a comprehension is reported no evidence
that any serious measures have been
taken to put an end to this practice
there are cases of torture with a
definite yes and we are not condoning
them and I don't think the government to
condone them and I don't think the
security forces should even should
exercise that I have issued statements
against capital punishments and again
how can you keep on all these years
representing a political establishment
with such a lousy human rights record
how long I've been fighting all mine
against human rights violations yeah
exactly not very successfully in your
own Miglia your own look land look at it
comprehensively yes we have been trying
we have prevented further violations we
have had laws in place we have had
institutions I think it's very easy to
sort of generalize and blame everything
but at the same time I think when I
reach the point of feeling that it's
absolutely hopeless and that we're going
down that path then of course I wouldn't
be here and I'm representing the
Palestinian people so what I've been
asking these questions about corruption
about brutality about repression about
crackdowns on journalists for the 25
years that I've been coming here and
every time I'm told you're addressing it
but it doesn't get done does it in many
ways but in many ways it does we don't
have a perfect system and there are
violations and we're not justifying them
but you're trying to provoke service so
that we will be seen as people who are
covering up we are not we are not and
those who do it have to be held to
account but these churches have become a
byword for for repression because we are
perceptions are different from reality
yes as long as you're as long as your
own sentiment example we have our own
public opinion polls and we know through
our own studies that the Palestinian
people in public do not condone any kind
of corruption do not condone any kind of
cruelty and we also know that the
perceptions are much higher than the
reality in terms of what's happening I
know this is what
mr. international dozen what we do we
measure perception but we also look at
reality and we look at instances and we
measure also improvements and we measure
cases we have prevented from going
beyond so you know how unpopular your
president is you know that his approval
rating is around 35% I dunno
yes yeah yes I do know and I and the
feeling that this is a legitimate
government which of course doesn't hold
elections at the house privates
poles inside fungi itself we need to
have election definitely it's the only
way to revitalize religious demise our
whole political system and I do not
condone the president or the government
or anybody holding back elections
whether it is Hamas or whether it is
better we need to have elections we need
to give our people the chance to judge
their own leadership and to change and
if you don't have elections why should
the international community keep pumping
money into this I think well the
national community to help us have
elections as well but you don't need for
but they do it in the expectation you've
got 100 more than 135 countries that
have now recognized the Palestinian yeah
and then say I recognize in the hope
that one day you might pass some
meaningful reforms and stop all this
abuse of human rights and the hope that
one day the occupation will end and we
will be a sovereign state in control of
all our institutions all our land or
loud resources that's what people have
invested them and they are you they
continue your internal feuds and battles
and MLS failure to recognize oil Hamas
and there has been a tech session I
admit we had accomplished tremendous
steps in terms of reform and
accountability unfortunately there has
been a serious regression and we're
admitting it and we're trying to fight
it now if you keep people in a prison
cell and you keep them subject to other
types of aggression and injustice and
corruption and so on by the occupation
you cannot blame them for everything now
the international community said that
they will invest in nation building and
state building in order to have that
two-state solution and they will invest
in get
a devolution of occupation because
ending the occupation is Iceni going on
for peace reassurances the two-state
solution is finished it is finished
you're either one speaker in it then
there is no hope of peace for a very
long time it is because Israel has
succeeded in taking over most of the
land that is Palestinian land 1967 we're
not talking about all the land we're not
talking about all of salary families are
offering you a straight - but we haven't
recovered from from Prime Minister
Netanyahu namely elegant and - extremely
arrogant and racist we recognized Israel
on 78 percent of historical Palace that
this might be the best one how we're
going to get and you may look back on it
has been coming of Palestinians look
back on this Camp David and Taba
as the best off in Arabic - you make you
may look back on this and wish you'd
taken it okay you're telling as if you
can steal a bit less and we have to
accept that we have agreed that Israel
exists on 78% of Palestine we want the
remaining 22% including East Jerusalem
and you cannot keep chipping away at
that
allowing Israel to act outside the law
to take more and more land more and more
resources to destroy the very viability
of the Palestinian state the very
territorial contiguous is an excuse me
the heart of the Palestinian state which
is Jerusalem dysentery Palestinians you
have to do with the pittance that you're
getting no but you keep turning down
offer after offer heaven you never get
any other offers you really want given a
state solution no I don't but there are
people who are saying it's inevitable
it's a de facto outcome would you
Israel's greed and I think we're getting
dangerously close to the end of a
two-state solution and I don't want to
see the de facto outcome of one state
solution because that means the
perpetuation of the occupation land
theft
oppression expulsion of Palestinians
home demolitions this is a very cruel
situation to have the Palestinians
in a situation where they have no dice
and when to tell them you have to accept
whatever Israel offers no Israel as well
I haven't seen any offers from Israel
let me see it but I'll tell you frankly
as well has to be bound by the law
Israeli impunity has to end terminal
Sharon hijack peace and it's kind of
nice hello thank you for being on
conflict on your mother thank you my
pleasure
[Music]